rodman giorno 8 ieri pensavo di aver
finito i tutorial delle feste e invece
oggi luigi mia mezzo costretto a fare
anche un albero di natale perché dentro
questa casa c'è una tristezza ci sono
quei ragni ricordiamo quello senza corpo
quello ancora tutto intero ma sono
comunque i ragni di halloween saluta
anche perché il problema di questa casa
scusate il problema di questa casa è che
non c'è spazio ora lasciate stare il
casinò però cioè non saprei dove
infilarlo in ordine esatto non è che ci
sia tanto spazio è ragazzi perdonatemi
per questo schifo davvero cioè in realtà
potrei dirvi che questa roba mi serve
per giro di blog ma la realtà che sta lì
da un mese questo è stato il regalo di
martina degli autori per la cucina
adesso il loro dovere e quello di morte
non ho idea di dove piazzarlo cosa che
senso lo attendiamo al soffitto
ma tipo al contrario come se fosse tipo
antigravitazionale pavia dove andiamo
viber rock masi si rubare stavo per dire
dobbiamo rubare un albero questo è
l'albero o minimalista chi mette un
albero così a casa sua
odia il natale più di me è quello lì
entra lui è scoglio albero slim pure gli
alberi stanno a dieta
albero
con la forfora forse abbiamo trovato il
nostro albero
perché tutti quanti si chiudono quindi i
rischi di montarlo e di averlo chiuso
per tutto il tempo
lui è forse giusto sia stata scelta alla
ricerca del fil di ferro per cercare di
detenuti nella struttura ma non
riusciamo nemmeno a tener a mente di un
carrello è nel frattempo sfrutto questa
occasione nella quale va dalle rho
merlin per prendermi anche a tavoletta
eccesso e dai secoli che è tipo il
coperchio di una pentola con la prende
la può causare dove ruolo in giro la
vogliamo rafa brucia non certo vanno a
ruba questi cori
stiamo tornando adesso dopo che ci sono
fatto un buco dico grande quanto una
capanna dentro perché bisogna trovare un
nastrino rosso perché senza questo
nastrino rosso mori mille di prezzo
dell'oro e quindi sto nastrino rosso ci
cambierà la vita
mamma mia non ci posso fare ho fame ho
fame sto guardando ritardo
poi qui e bronx qua dentro quasi
parcheggiano pure qua dietro arrivano da
dietro così il comet e parcheggiano
guarda che carino
cielo rubiamo portava a casa
toh nastrino rosso di 20 ore dopo
abbiamo mangiato in piedi correndo
praticamente abbiamo girato 20 negozi
alla ricerca di questo e un assist e
rino è però l'abbiamo tra te non ci
siamo fermati che non abbiamo trovato ma
non quello che volevo dire io odio il
motore non ci credo ci abbiamo fatto
siamo tornati a casa ma quella è una
lampada mi sono comprato da sostituire
con quella e quell'albero io sono morto
cioè non dobbiamo metterci a fare
l'albero e per di più non solo un albero
norma appenderlo su ecco lo sapevo
minerebbe da fare per l'albero che sia
scartate che guarda un po di libri sotto
mettiamo più sono a posto ora
giustamente siamo riusciti a prendere
comunque un albero che va messo il suo
giusto quindi in giù di entro sta roba
qui ma facciamo un tentativo lo montiamo
intanto tutto quanto e vediamo cosa
succede quando lo ribalta può allora non
sappiamo se verrà bello se verranno
possiamo dirlo forse tornando indietro
sarebbe stato meglio comprare lo su
amazon band i panni spende i panetti per
polipo dei calzini dell'ikea cosa
importantissima e che se fate questo
albero di natale
fate in modo di aver fatto comunque
l'antitetanica perché secondo me la
rischiate a ogni carezza cioè che si è
cambiato ma nel frattempo l'albero come
vedete è pieno di fil di ferro che cosa
giusta forma come nella struttura
giustissima che è stato prodotto in
tutti i programmi
credo che se arrivato il momento della
verità la verità è che siamo vestiti in
maniera inchiavabile giriamo l'albero
tac o o è andata è carinissimo ammazza
st perfetto ma perché non hanno sempre
fatto gli alberi al contrario thinking
al benin creek menziona può vedere
quanto sono qui sponge una moda a terra
in mare calzino di lana concia battazza
di plastica
anche qui inchiavabile mazza il rogo
loro è tanta
né c'è fascio l'albero invece faccio mi
ci faccio io sono mamma mia perché 70
metri luci
lei ha voluto tu sia giusta conosciuta
diventano invece che riprende epoca da
carlo ii il mio amico thomas l'avete già
visto in vita buttata in passato gli
avevo detto che avevo voglia di passare
il pomeriggio insieme non sapeva che era
solamente una scusa per sfruttarlo per
mondo sì ma non ho idea di come andiamo
effettivamente non pensandoci sarebbe
stato meglio chiedere aiuto a un tavolo
intanto il creativo ha preso tutti i
miei suggerimenti grande creativo batti
cinque credevo in via rossi cosa che
facciamo come grande idea per natale
niente l'albero invisibile comunque
esistono gli alberi e presepi manovra
esistono gli ambienti vaticani capovolti
fatti apposta perché non vogliamo essere
i fondi ha capito di avere di sarebbe
carino anche vederlo smontare poi non
puoi saperlo promessa femminile a
tenerlo su gli devi dare fuoco secondo
me gli scarpini fuoco maschera oggi ci
vede cinque in un sacco di rete saputo
bastardo eliminato per macchine chitarre
che dipendono sbagliato del sole
da casa con quadro tempo racconta al una
mano estratte verrà contrario c'è il
male ragazzi non vediamo un po se devo
avere l'ansia delle tipo l'anticristo in
casa scherzi a parte il momento
sondaggio mi hanno già chiamato un prete
esorcista perché dice che secondo lei
sono il figlio di satana anticristo ora
vorrei capire da voi ma secondo voi non
era buffo e simpatico come come
esperimento o veramente c'è il demonio
all'interno di questo gesto
vi prego vi prego domani partendo una
cesoia spacconata o con quel cielo
spazio sebbene in piedi prete mi diceva
che c'era satana gli ho detto no ci sono
60 metri quadrati
allora dalla bella ripassata questo la
portare però ci sono delle spalle senza
buco usate quelle le sanremo luigi
esatto luigi st volevo fare niente
inserisco i figli dentro e io vaccino e
lui no vi chiedo perdono per la quantità
di doppi sensi presenti all'interno di
questo dialogo peggio è passato
ancora non lo so comunque posso dire sta
tenendo molto carino molto molto bene di
una fortissima hai da dire ripassato
adesso che la cosa positiva è che questo
puntale finalmente stare dritto in
seguito molto po ma chi o cosa hanno
pensato quando hanno fatto questo albero
sicuramente non è che tu la pensi al
contrario questo penso che è segnata una
scuola e la porta
così chi è questo puntare non andrà mai
in giù perché già in giù pazzesco voi
continuate a lavorare che state cosa due
richiami voi state facendo tutti suo
sporco lavoro ma che bella questa
pallina quale l'ho scelta io anche
questa l'ho scelta io e anche questa è
bella anche questa l'uscita io grazie
aver scelto le palline migliori e se è
meglio chi è che ha messo sotto la scala
tutti quanti secondo me sei tu che l'hai
fatto e non te ne sei reso conto che la
vita in mano la scopa si è fatto molto
bene non sono fatto molto bene il mio
regno cosa pensa lei si è aggirato
apposta per non vederlo ha veramente
penso che tutto questo pero non fate la
causa ma ti ripeto guglielmo esistono
gli alberi quelli proprio fare l'albero
raggiungere questo occorre dire no ma
sul tuo collo ce n'è solo una ribadire
che per comprarlo questo lo tagliamo
effettivamente ah ah ah ah ah questa è
la rossa non è finita non è finita il
santo scritta adesso faremo dei
pacchetti a tale da mettere al contrario
stacchiamo guadagni perfetto sai che c'è
hanno fatto il loro tempo sono molto
carini sono perfetti però è giusto che
adesso loro vadano dove meritano di
andare ora creiamo dei finti pacchi
natalizi anche perché qua non so quanto
vedrà regali quest'anno poiché ti faccio
un po di spazio sul tavolo quando sono
abituato a lavorare in condizioni delle
nostre aree teverina questo molto
ragazzi segreto vorrei un paese o
metterli parti al posto dei laghi tra
sempre che vivo farsi da notare questo
momento io faccio i pacchi c'è il look e
fare coccarde mette tutto insieme e
thomas che si sbagliano sky hd o mio dio
tu che fai o l'ultimo pacchetto è anche
la hd q8 frenata lettera adesso ho
lottato bella udc miti molto carino
cascano in faccia e vabbè capirai
importate che non cada l'albero che
quello che lettera abbiamo fatto intanto
è ripartito alieno è arrivato molto
molto ogni materia che uno faccia sapere
cari e carino non sto per mettere
un'altra ditta sì siamo molto tutti
curiosi
aspettando da non rilascerò pertanto
voglio dire signor è carino che farà che
il proprio carino procedi piccola tv ma
scusate perché non stiamo facendo questa
cosa mentre sentiamo le canzoni di
mariah carrey o oca che verrebbero le
basi bisogna rimediare bisogna rimediare
ai veloce veloce veloce che si rimedia
si rimedia si rimedia eccola eccola
quando canti con la musica sotto ti
senti michael bublé poi tiri ascolti e
sembri una mucca che muggisce morandi se
non gli fa ottenere carisma da mariah
che dire ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta
ecco l'albero non ti osta è prima prima
a mi stanca sto cosa faccio più e stato
bello addio addio e dopo aver montato
d'altronde montare la tavoletta decesso
ma alla fine abbiamo puntato per questo
grigio un po new york un po sica go ma
sempre con stile a posto ho fallito
eccola lì ecco larino eccolo lì tenente
ho scoperto che più facile montare un
albero al contrario che una tavoletta
successo di una cosa levati un attimo
come fai con me perciò voglio farti fare
una risata che è un modo per dirmi che
ho fatto un regalo ma non ti montare la
testa ma si mangia si parla che è un
regalo apprezzato perché fino a questa
ripresa che davanti con un albero
contrario indietro farti sorridere ci
siamo proprio salvati si mangia
bastoncino maggio nuovo ammazzano di
farlo aprire ma sono io e ci sei tu che
ci sono le cambiali puliti e stanca
quelle che ti esplode in bocca e
lasciano fare contento con i computer e
caramelle praticamente lo rende felici
abilità e frizzi pazzi si chiamano
libero piccolo rino così ma adesso sono
di altro genere missioni bar primi
palazzi grande grazie belle frizzi e
pazzini
quindi noi chiudiamo domani con il
prossimo alle 14 nello 0 questa volta sì
ma cambiamo tu hai fatto una pallina nel
centro preferito ma tu potresti iniziare
un business un mistery baldini ma
ragazzi ragazzi tutto il talento ma sai
quante persone credono ancora nell'amore
vorrebbero una cosa così cioè noi
abbiamo qua la palla con maschi 3 fatta
tosi anche lione babbo natale con le
facce ma che carini e tutto questo con
la con l'acca dopo il nastrino rosso
come giovanni muciaccia anche questo
adesso io dentro dalle linee dei
cristalli di breaking bad
wow bella grazie grazie mille luigi ciao